les intégrations dans les grandes écoles
correspondent à une certaine forme
d'élection chaque école cherche ainsi à
élire les étudiants qui selon elle
mérite le plus d'être de futurs anciens
élèves de leur établissement sauf que ce
n'est pas vraiment l'école qui décide
l'école à l'instar d'un pays n'a pas
vraiment de préférence en tant que tel
ce sont les individus les dirigeants le
citoyen qui ont des préférences mais
comme ses dirigeants des écoles ne
connaissent pas bien leur candidat ils
ne vont pas choisir directement
bien souvent ils vont délégué l'élection
des candidats aux professeurs ce sont
ces professeurs qui vont chercher à y
lire les étudiants qui selon eux mérite
veut plus d'intégrer l'école pour se
faire au lieu de voter le nom du
meilleur étudiant qui l'ont uc ou un
classement des étudiants les professeurs
vont voter en attribuant une note à
chaque étudiant le processus électoral
va ensuite agrégés les notes et des
différents professeurs en en prenant la
valeur moyenne avec typiquement
davantage de poids pour certains
professeurs dont la note semble
davantage s'aligner avec les préférences
des dirigeants de l'école
et si on faisait pareil pour nos hommes
politiques et si au lieu de voter pour
un candidat en particulier
on notait tous les candidats sur une
échelle de 0 à 20 ou pourrait ensuite
élire le candidat avec la meilleure
moyenne
cette idée peut vous paraître farfelue
aujourd'hui pourtant elle avait été
proposée par le mathématicien jean
charles de borda dès 1770 oui 1770 c'est
avant la révolution française et avant
l'indépendance des états unis d'amérique
autant dire qu'au moment où de borda
propose son scrutin ce sont les scrutins
à un tour et à deux tours auxquels on
s'est habitués qu'ils sont farfelues le
scrutin à la de borda permettrait de
grandement augmenter notre pouvoir
expressif au moment du vote
au lieu de dire je vote pour ce candidat
ou je vote pour cette proposition de loi
on pourrait alors transmettre plus
d'informations via notre vote en
précisant pour chaque candidat et chaque
proposition de loi à quel point on
aimerait que ce candidat devienne le
futur président de la république ou que
cette loi soit la prochaine législation
à suivre qui plus est d'un point de vue
mathématique le scrutin la de borda
permettrait de contourner les
difficultés posées par les trois
théorème antidémocratique dans son
appareil dans l'épisode précédent
puisque ces trois terrains ne s'applique
qu'à des préférences dit ordinale
c'est à dire des préférences qui
s'exprime sous la forme je préfère x ou
y à z en particulier le théorème
d'arreau ne s'applique désormais plus il
devient maintenant possible d'agréger
des préférences individuelles en une
préférence deux groupes ont satisfaisant
l'unanimité et l'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes super
notons nos candidats donc pas si vite
il ya une raison pour laquelle on
n'utilise pas déjà le scrutin de deux
bordas après tout il est pas nouveau il
a été inventé en 1770 le scrutin par
notation a été vivement critiqué à juste
titre par le véritable némésis de de
borda à savoir le marquis de condorcet
dont on parlera dans le prochain épisode
pour commencer il ya le point de
l'échelle des notes ne tous notre façon
de mettre des notes et du coup les notes
et d'un électeur ne seront pas forcément
comparable aux notes d'un autre électeur
un 10 sur 20 au concours de l'ena ce
n'est pas vraiment comparable un 10 sur
20 à l'examen de la jop d une façon de
yves de corriger ces problèmes d'échelle
consisterait à normaliser les notes d'un
électeur de sorte que la note moyenne
donnée par un électeur soit égale à 10
et que l'écart type soit égale à 5
mais du coup quand il y a peu de
candidats cette normalisation va
dépendre de l'ensemble des candidats qui
se sont présentés
autrement dit on va perdre
l'indépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes et puis dans le cadre des
professeurs il ya une seconde difficulté
qu'une vraie difficulté 1 pour les
écoles notamment qui est le fait que
l'ensemble des candidats noté par un
professeur diffèrent selon le professeur
or la normalisation des notes pour un
professeur donné dépend de l'ensemble
des candidats qu'il aura à noter encore
une fois celui qui a juste la moyenne à
l'oeil mais ce n'est pas forcément
comparable à celui qui est juste la
moyenne à l'examen de la jop des brefs
agrégé des préférences cardinal c'est à
dire exprimer sous forme de notes en
fait bien moins évident que ce que ça
peut en avoir l'air et on reviendra plus
longuement sur cette difficulté majeure
plus tard dans notre série sur la
démocratie mais il ya une critique bien
plus fatales aux scrutins de de borda le
dilemme du vote utile
supposons que les sondages montrent que
l'élection du plus grand théoricien des
jeux de l'histoire se jouera entre deux
bordas et condorcet et moi j'ai
peut-être envie de mettre 17 sur 20 ha
de borda et 19 sûrement à condom
c'est will j'admire de bordeaux mais
j'adule condorcet et je veux vraiment
que ce soit condorcet qui deviennent le
plus grand théoricien des jeux de
l'histoire du coup plutôt que voter mais
vrai préférence j'aurais intérêts a
complètement les exagérer et a donné
typiquement 20 sur 20 un condensé et 0
sur 20 ha de borda ça serait là un vote
utile puisqu'il favoriserait les chances
d'élection de condorcet et maintenant si
tout le monde agit de la sorte et vote
utile il faut s'attendre à ce que toutes
les notes soient ou bien 20 sur 20 ou
bien un zéro sur vingt est pas trop
d'utiliser un vote au milieu dès lors
les résultats du vote ne refléterait pas
du tout les préférences cardinal des
électeurs il ne refléterait que leur
vote utile et ça ça délégitimise aurait
le résultat de l'élection si on utilise
le scrutin de deux bandas n'encourage
exagérations et la mauvaise foi et les
résultats du vote ne refléteront pas
vraiment les vrais préférence des
électeurs et c'est pour ça que le
scrutin de deux bandas on l'a un peu mis
à la poubelle
vous alors pourquoi ne pas modifier le
système de vote en anticipant les
exagérations des électeurs voilà qui
correspondrait à forcer les électeurs à
voter 0 ou vent ou dit autrement ça
consisterait à demander à chaque
électeur et pour chaque candidat
si l'électeur consenti à l'élection du
candidat scrutin que je décris la est
appelée scrutin par assentiment on
l'appelle aussi scrutin par approbation
et depuis quelques années on utilise de
plus en plus en effet le scrutin par
assentiment n'est autre que doodle.com
ce site est particulièrement utilisé
pour élire la date d'une réunion
les électeurs sont les membres de la
réunion et pour chaque date proposée
chaque électeur doit annoncer s'il
consentie ou non à la date en question
je recommande vivement ce scrutin pour
prendre des décisions peu importantes
par exemple imaginez que vous soyez
entre amis et qu'il vous faut décider
entre eux le cinéma le billard et le
bowling et bien proposé chaque
alternative est compté le nombre de vos
amis qui consentent à chacune des
alternatives
l'alternative qui aura le plus de voix
sera élu lui autrement le scrutin par
assentiment n'est autre qu'un scrutin à
un tour où chaque électeur a le droit de
voter pour plusieurs candidats
ce scrutin est largement meilleur que
scrutin à toi ne serait ce parce qu'il
est indépendant aux alternatives non
pertinentes
cependant et pas vraiment génial non
plus puisqu'il expose encore à les
électeurs au dilemme du vote utile
en effet si je sais que ça va se jouer
entre de borda et condorcet mais je vais
voter contre de borda même si en vrai
j'approuve l'élection de deux bandas en
tant que plus grand théoricien de
l'histoire par ailleurs la légitimité du
candidat élu pas évidente à défendre du
cloud est ce qu'il faut abandonner
l'idée de noter nos politiciens est-ce
qu'il faut abandonner les méthodes à la
de bordeaux peut-être pas
suite au séisme de l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 dont on a parlé
dans l'épisode 2 le mathématicien michel
balinski se demanda s'il n'était pas
temps de raviver les idées de deux
bordas en mieux il joue en force avec le
mathématicien maroco-française rida
laraki les deux chercheurs proposèrent
une nouvelle façon de combiner des notes
fournies par des électeurs qu'ils
appelèrent le jugement majoritaire
l'idée du jugement majoritaire est
d'associer à chaque candidat
la note médiane que les électeurs lui
ont donné par exemple si condorcet
reçoit les notes 19 7 16 18 et 5 alors
sa note médiane se calcule en ré
ordonnant les notes l'ordre croissant et
en sélectionnant la note qui se trouve
au milieu
dans notre exemple la note médiane de
condenser et donc 16 on peut interpréter
cette médiane comme suit une majorité
des électeurs pensent que condorcet et
mérite c'est sur 20 ou plus et l'autre
majorité des électeurs pensent qu'il
mérite c'est sur 20 ou moins d'où la
notion de jugement majoritaire
de même on calcule les notes médiane des
autres candidats et le candidat avec la
meilleure note médiane était le en
pratique plutôt qu'une note sur 20
bein ce qui est l'arrêt qui propose un
jugement entre très mauvais est
excellent mais ça change pas grand chose
ce qui est génial c'est l'idée de la
médiane en effet la médiane est une
mesure beaucoup plus fiable beaucoup
plus robuste est beaucoup moins
manipulable que la moyenne
par exemple supposons que j'essaie de
faire gagner condorcet alors je ne peux
pas augmenter la note de condorcet
puisque je vais déjà donné une note qui
était supérieure à 16 de la même manière
je peux pas diminuer la note de borda
puisque elle note que je lui est
attribuée est déjà inférieur à 18 je ne
peux donc pas affecter l'issue de
l'élection en votant autre chose que mes
vrais préférence et ça ça veut dire que
les résultats du scrutin correspondront
beaucoup mieux aux préférences des
électeurs que ce n'est le cas par
exemple dans un scrutin à deux toits
mieux encore le jugement majoritaire et
indépendant aux alternatifs non
pertinentes et ça c'est une propriété
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 2 qui est
très importante pour le futur de nos
sociétés
bref jugement majoritaire à de très très
bonnes propriétés alors
pour être honnête c'est pas tout à fait
mon scrutin préféré en partie parce que
j'ai fait de la recherche sur un autre
scrutin à la condorcet et mon oncle et
un de ses albums lee émotionnellement à
condorcet mais aussi parce que le
jugement majoritaire ne ferme pas
complètement la porte au dilemme du vote
utile
même s'il est beaucoup mieux à cet égard
que tous les scrutins que l'on à
aujourd'hui
en effet imaginons que les notes
attribuées à 2 bordas était en fête
17 15 20 13 19
alors cette fois je pourrais faire
gagner condensé en montant sur ma
préférence cardinal vis-à-vis de borda
et en lui donnant 15 plutôt que 17
ceci étant dit je veux pas vous donner
l'impression que je m'oppose au jugement
majoritaire si je devais me noter je lui
donnerai peut-être 17 sur 20 c'est pas
un 20 sur 20 qui annote que je donnerai
rabon scrutin préféré mais c'est
beaucoup mieux que le 2 sur 20 et le 5
sur 20 que je donnera au scrutin à un
tour et à deux tours comme je le dis
dans l'épisode 2 l'une de mes grandes
inquiétudes pour le futur de l'humanité
et la bi polarisation idéologique
croissante
je suis persuadé que la dépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes et le
dilemme du vote utile en sont une cause
majeure
il est urgent d'adopter des scrutins
avec de biens meilleures propriétés et
le jugement majoritaire est l'un de ces
scrutins
nader fin on a parlé de trois théorème
antidémocratique et de la l'autocratie
et damien ouverte et bien de rajouter
que ces théories ne s'applique qu'au cas
où on a au moins trois alternatives et
on a pas mal parmi vous qui ont fait la
remarque à juste titre que pour les
jurés en fait c'est coupable ou pas
coupable du coussin choix binaire et
pour un choix binaire les trois théorème
antidémocratique ne s'applique pas mais
si on demandait aux jurés de prendre une
décision un peu plus que coupable et pas
coupable et en pratique c'est quand même
important de savoir à quel point il est
coupable
quelles sont les circonstances
atténuantes et tout ça pour pouvoir
prendre une décision finale qui n'est
pas à la culpabilité ou là donc peu
habitée mais qu'est la sentence pour
déterminer une sentence cette fois il ya
beaucoup de possibilités
un an deux ans avec sursis et plein
d'autres combinaisons compliquées et à
ce moment là il ya plus de trois
possibilités
du coup les trois théorème
antidémocratique ça pique de dragon ball
29 nous fait la remarque que ce qu était
un alternatif il a quand même un gros
défaut qui est la non monotonie cité qui
implique d'ailleurs le deuxième pilote
du team et le fait que si tout à coup en
fait il un candidat que vous trouvez
bien le monte dans vos préférences est
possible que ça nuise à ce candidat et
que du coup en augmentant son classement
dans votre vote vous empêcher son
élection et je vous renvoie vers
l'excellence vidéo de son étonnante qui
donne un exemple ou sur le lien enfin il
y en a pas mal parmi vous qui vont faire
regretter pas mal le fait qu'on puisse
pas éditer les vidéos youtube puisque
n'a pas mal paru vous qui m'ont parlé de
la différence entre démocratie
représentative et démocratie directe où
le semis direct ou et qui toutes ses
versions de la démocratie où l'idée ça
serait un peu de contourner les hommes
politiques et en particulier là où je
regrette beaucoup que je ne puisse pas
éditer la vidéo précédente
c'est que si c'était à refaire je ré
expliquerait beaucoup mieux ce qui se
passe dans la démocratie athénienne
il faut savoir qu'à la démocratie
athénienne c'est super compliqué c'est
pas juste
on tire au hasard des gens et les
joueurs décident déjà il ya plusieurs
façons de beauté il ya l'assemblée des
500 qui sont tirés au hasard main très
il ya des référendums qui sont faits sur
la place publique
et puis encore d'autres systèmes qui
sont beaucoup plus oligarchique c'est à
dire où il faut avoir des compétences
pour pouvoir y accéder et où les
institutions qui sont non moins
démocratique juste pour avoir une idée
de quel point la démocratie athénienne
est en fait super compliqué aussi un
graphique qui est tiré de la page
wikipedia sur la démocratie athénienne
mais surtout le point très très très
importants sur lesquels il faut que
j'insiste c'est que même si on a un
système démocratique beaucoup plus
direct où les citoyens tirés au hasard
par exemple vous rédigez des lois ou
prendre des décisions
il reste un problème de scrutin
particulier soit vous avez très peu de
gens qui sont chargés d'écrire les lois
du coup il ya moins de problèmes de
scrutin mais du coup va avoir plus
d'aller à tort puisque les lois qui vont
être rédigée vont dépendre de moins de
personnes soit vous essayez d'avoir une
assemblée de personnes tirées au hasard
qui représente mieux les différentes
préférences de tout le peuple et à ce
moment là si vous avez 10 personnes qui
commençait à interagir pour écrire la
loi il ya un vrai problème de scrutin
qui s'opposent en particulier dès que
vous commencez à mettre beaucoup de
personnes qui doivent trouver sur une
même loi
ça va devenir très très très difficile
d'aboutir un consensus où tout le monde
est d'accord sur une loi à implémenter
et du coup va falloir faire des
compromis et la façon de faire des
compromis
c'est un problème de scrutin plus
généralement le scrutin c'est pas juste
aller aux urnes pour élire un président
le problème du scrutin de façon très
générale c'est on a plusieurs personnes
et on doit prendre une décision qui
s'applique à toutes ces personnes à tout
l'électorat quel que soit ce quels que
soient les lectorats en question et ce
problème vous le retrouvez partout des
capteurs personnes qui doivent
s'organiser pour coopérer ensemble l'une
des raisons on préfère se tourner vers
quelques dirigeants qui commande qui
prennent les décisions de façon un peu
plus dictatoriale c'est à mon sens en
partie à cause de la difficulté à
prendre des décisions collectives que
souligner l'étroite et aurait menti
démocratique donc là je sais que les
démocratie directe gagne de plus en plus
en popularité
notamment il ya un documentaire que je
vous invite à voir sur le sujet
cependant je trouve que le documentaire
prend largement partie pour une
démocratie beaucoup plus direct ou
participatif est à mon sens le
documentaire est pas du tout à ces
critiques sur les problèmes que posent à
démocratie beaucoup plus dira il
beaucoup plus participative notamment à
la fin faut quand même que arriver à
créer des lois qui convienne à tout le
peuple et c'est quelque chose qui reste
difficile si on prend des gens au hasard
pour faire une assemblée en particulier
tout un pan de recherche qui s'appelle
la recherche sur la démocratie
délibérative et je vous conseille cet
excellent article qui a été écrit par
michael berg qui fait un peu un résumé
de pas mal de résultats par différentes
recherches en sociologie notamment et ce
papier montre que la démocratie
délibérative c'est super compliqué c'est
loin d'être quelque chose de facile qui
suffit de mettre des gens ensemble et
vont trouver des bonnes lois
en fait dès que vous avez pas mal de
gens d'avoir des problèmes de dominance
des gens qui vont avoir meilleur
rhétorique d'autres qui vont devenir des
personnes plus importante et va avoir un
système finalement représentatif qui va
apparaître au sein de l'assemblée
délibérative et je passe aussi sous
silence des problèmes vis-à-vis majorité
versus minorité c'est vraiment pas
facile à régler
je vois encore vraiment la lecture de
cet article si vous êtes persuadé que la
démocratie participative délibérative
direct est la solution à tous nos
problèmes
cet article va vous montrer qu'en fait
beaucoup moins évident que ça il ya un
excellent commentaire de yens des cons
parce que je vous invite à lire qui
parle un peu plus du système qui est
utilisée en suisse et de ses limites en
particulier des décisions à prendre à
l'échelle de tous pays des décisions sur
l'économie sur des lois du travail et
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
complexes qui sont beaucoup moins
évidentes a traité via l'e démocratie
directe notamment parce que bien souvent
c'est pas juste oui ou non c'est des
trucs beaucoup plus
compliqué beaucoup de possibilités et à
ce moment là les trois taux et
d'antidémocratique s'applique elle
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
vous invite vraiment réfléchir à ce
scrutin majoritaire a plus généralement
ou scrutin de voir vraiment que le
premier scrutin est un vrai problème
fondamental qui est le problème de
comment prendre des décisions à
plusieurs pour plusieurs et de façon à
tenir en compte des préférences de
chacun d'entre nous comme vous l'avez
compris j'ai un gros faible pour un
autre scrutin
et cet autre sous contrat c'est ce dont
on parlera dans le prochain épisode qui
est le scrutin de condorcet dit
randomisés si vous avez aimé cet épisode
tant sialique et à le commenter à les
partager pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
team apollo et j'espère vraiment que
pour le prochain épisode qui parlera de
dix coureurs préférés disent rien chaque
candidat est jugé individuellement sur
son mérite personnel
indépendamment des autres et donc on n'a
pas le problème des petites candidatures
qui vont influencer l'issue du scrutin
ici s'il ya plus de petites candidatures
ça ne va pas changer la mention
majoritaire qu'un candidat va recevoir
donc pourquoi le jury majoritaire il
évite les paradoxes et élit le candidat
le plus consensuel qui est le mieux
évalué par les habitants